Should be this.
And you mentioned these ideas of
responsibility,
of virtue of respect.
You've,
I think,
detailed what you think students
shouldn't do in these examples of like
protests and these examples of certain
types of activist tactics.
What advice would you have for students?
How can students make the changes that
they want to make?
Particularly,
do you have any advice for students
here?
Yeah.
Read great books.
Really,
man,
you've got this four year period that
has been carved out of your lives by
society.
They,
they,
it's,
it's given you an identity,
like a high quality identity and freedom
at the same time.
And you're not going to get that again
in your life.
You've got to,
you've got a respectable identity,
university students and complete freedom
associated with that or as near as
you're ever going to get.
And you've got these unbelievable
libraries that are full of the writings
of people who are,
who are intelligent and articulate
beyond comprehension and,
you know,
and,
and you can go there and you can learn
all this and you might think,
well,
why should you learn it?
Um,
well you learn it to get a job or you
learn it to get good grades or you learn
it to get a degree.
And that's all nonsense.
It's nonsense.
The reason that you come to university
to be educated is because there is
nothing more powerful than someone who
is articulate and who can think and
speak.
It's power and I mean power of the best,
sort of its authority and influence and
respectability and competence.
And so you come to university to craft
your highest skill and your highest
skill is to be found in articulated
speech.
And if you're,
if you're,
if you're a master at formulating your
arguments,
you win everything.
And better than that,
when you win everything,
everyone around you wins too.
Because to transform yourself into,
let's consider you consider your
transformation,
does something approximating the logos.
It means you shine a light on the whole
world.
Well,
there's nothing more exciting to do with
that.
There's nothing better you can possibly
do.
And to think that you're going to
university to be,
you know,
trained to have a job,
it's like great.
That's a hell of a lot better than being
unemployed and covered with cheeto dust
while you're snacking away in front of
your video game in the basement.
But it's not.
It's not a,
and I don't want to have anything
against video games by the way,
but it's hardly a triumphant call to,
to being in the world.
And that's what universities should be
calling forth.
It's like God,
you people,
you,
you know,
I know what Harvard students are like.
I taught here for five years.
You people are spectacular.
You're spectacular.
You're,
you're,
you're all capable of being world
beaters.
You transform yourself into something
that's articulated and sensible and
grounded in history and knowledgeable
and wise.
Man,
you can do anything you want and
hopefully anything you want for good
because if you have any sense,
everything you want to do would be for
the good because there's nothing more
compelling or meaningful or,
or useful in combating the tragedy of
life than to,
than to struggle with all your soul on
behalf the good and the universities and
forgotten that.
It's why everyone's bailing out of the
humanities and they should.
The humanities are corrupt.
They're corrupt because they're not
telling the students this.
It's so bloody obvious.
It's like learn to think,
learn to speak room to read.
It makes you a super power and
individual superpower.
You have it under.
I don't understand why that isn't just
told to students.
It's not that hard to understand it.
Everyone wants to hear it.
It's like,
really?
I could do this.
I can do that.
It's like,
yeah,
really you could do that and the whole
society around you is labored for really
thousands of years to provide every
single one of you with this spectacular
opportunity that you have while your
undergraduates and graduate students
here,
man,
they're just,
everyone's just praying that you would
come here and manifest everything that
you could manifest and that's what you
should be doing.
Instead of waving plaque cards and
complaining about how your old pressed
for God's sake,
you see these Yale students complaining
about their oppression.
It's just,
it just leaves me aghast.
It's like,
well,
we're against the ruling class.
It's like,
no,
no.
Your baby ruling class members,
you're young.
The
only reason you're not rich is cause
you're young.
You know that's the best.
Really.
That's the,
if you look at the 1%,
even the dreaded 1% you know,
most of those people are old.
Why?
Well,
when you progress through life,
if you're reasonably successful,
you trade in your promising youth for
your wealthy old age,
but you're still bloody old you when you
trade it.
Would you trade your youth for that?
Like if you factor age out of the
economic equation,
things look a lot different.
One.
Of course,
older people have more money.
If they have any sense,
they'd been collecting it for their
whole life.
Is that somehow unfair?
It's not unfair unless you want to want
to be poverty stricken when you're 70
and you and you don't want to be
poverty,
strict pop poverty stricken when you
were 17 so I just don't understand
what's happened to the universities.
I can't believe that you're not told
when you come the first day,
look man,
you are right.
You're here on a heroic mission.
You're going to take your capacity to
articulate yourself to levels that are
undreamed of,
you're going to come out of here.
I'm unstoppable.
You're going to be able to do anything
you want.
It's like that's what you're here for.
Instead,
you're taught that,
well,
you know the world's a pretty oppressive
place and you're probably the bottom of
the victim pile and,
and,
and there's,
there's virtually nothing you can do
about it except no deconstruct the
patriarchy and it's so rude deed and so
pathetic that,
that the university should be
embarrassed that that's what they're
peddling to students.
I'm embarrassed by it.
You know,
I've gone on public record telling
parents,
how do you well,
send your boys to trade school because
at least they'll learn something useful.
And that's a terrible thing for someone
like me to say because I do believe that
the,
the being articulated in educated in the
highest possible manner is there's
nothing that's better for you and for
society.
And why are the why of the university's
forgotten this?
Well,
that's postmodern neo Marxism for you.
Then the philosophy of intense
resentment and oppression and group
identity and god,
it's just.